[Applause]  I need you to do as I tell you I need to  get you on the boy away from you  did you see everything you needed to see  I saw enough why is the water dropped  why does the sword reveal itself now  [Music]  I've never had any power or any desire  to achieve it  that's all the fuss is about don't worry  you'll soon understand what all the fuss  is about are you scared I think I can  manage you should be scared never it  takes to hunt any down  Michael Tony fooling him the pretty  girls time you followed me  you want him to think big give you  something big to think about  you wanted to propagate  this is your top seed  the man who pulled sword through stone  behold  you're born king  you  [Music]  you